Charles III sera Versailles ce mercredi
20 septembre le nouveau roi d'Angleterre
participera un dîner d'État dans la
galerie des Glaces du château il dînera
avec la reine Kamiya en présence du
président Emmanuel Macron et de 150 à
180 convives à partir de 20h je suis
très content parce que je trouve que
c'est bien d'avoir des bons rapports
avec tous les gens importants de tous
les pays donc non je trouve ça très bien
le château c'est quand même c'est comme
une sacrée un sacré monument et ça fait
toujours plaisir de savoir qu'une qu'une
personne comme ça vient visiter le
château de Versailles une visite d'État
qui aura des conséquences sur la
circulation elle sera interrompu le
mercredi 20 septembre entre 16h et une
nuit autour du château de Versailles
parmi les principales rues bloqués il y
aura les rues de l'Indépendance
américaine Colbert et des réservoirs les
avions Rockefeller Saint-Julien et de la
Chancellerie sont également fermées il
sera également interdit de stationner
autour du château de Versailles entre ce
mardi 20h et ce mercredi minuit je
pensais beaucoup de choses pour
au final juste la venue du prince
Charles
dans l'année c'est pas dramatique cette
visite à Versailles est un clin d'oeil à
la reine Elizabeth II selon le palais de
l'Élysée la souveraine avait visité le
château lors de sa première visite
officielle en France en tant que reine
en 1957 avant d'y retourner en 1972